where does this expression come from it
has some very particular pieces to it
the 10x that's the easy bit what does
that represent on the diagram what does
that promote yeah well there's a
rectangle right so your your structure
here has a rectangular bit down the
bottom it's just gonna width and a
height and then what about this other
bit hanging out with the square root
where's that from
that's from there's there's this thing
up here right now there are some
telltale signs in here that give you
clues for example when you see the
square root and the two things
underneath the square root are both
squares what should that immediately
make you think of Pythagoras right and
hopefully you did like get that mental
cue it was a bit of a sort of
encouragement from us like you know you
can work this out fairly quickly so you
end up with this expression now part two
please pay careful attention to this and
before we actually launch into it I'll
just explain why part two leads us to
put in a part three it says find the
distance between the vertical sides that
maximizes the area of the front bar in
front of the bar right so you're looking
for 2x that's what you're looking for
aren't you because on the diagram there
you can see that is the distance between
the vertical sides okay but you can see
that that's different to part three part
three is well what's the actual area so
they're trying to separate that out so
you remember I've got to work out two
things okay so in order to do part two
the calculus part clearly we need a
derivative now I know a lot of you sort
of panicked when you saw that cuz you
like gross this is going to be
disastrous okay this is one of the
reasons why we give you this in part one
because you guys have seen questions
before where we don't give you this you
have to work it out on your own and just
have to like good luck and make sure
it's right on your own this time we give
it to you so that you know even though
you can't with something weird it's
right it's us trying to encourage you in
the right direction so this is messy you
are going to have to differentiate this
mess so let's do one piece at a time
this bits easy derivative of 10x is 10
okay that was the easy part when you
come to this because it's quite a lot of
mental gymnastics involved here I like
to separate out this problem into a
couple of cases so
if I say this is U and V right I'm
obviously going to have to use the
peripheral here but I'm gonna have to
use more than the price rule to
differentiate V what am I going to need
to use chain rule very good function of
a function so over here I'm going to
write V separately and I encourage you
if you don't do this when you're doing
your derivative if it's a complicated
one do a separate piece so if you're
following on with your own working do
this I'm going to write it in the form
that makes it most useful right this is
actually a hundred minus x squared
raised to what power 1/2 and using this
now it's ready for chain rule okay so
I'm just gonna get re - out of this what
do I do what is what are the two parts
of chain rule inside and outside so
we'll do it in that order it doesn't
matter
the derivative the inside function is
minus 2x it's just that's that component
bit so I'll just Chuck that out the
front and now I have to do the outside
the outside is something to the power of
1/2 and I know how to deal with that
we'll bring the power down we will
reduce the power by 1 and we're done
okay I mean it's messy but that's the
derivative okay we can tidy up a little
bit I suppose the 1/2 and the 2 will
cancel that negative 1/2 means it's
actually on the denominator so correct
me if I'm wrong but it looks to me like
this is what we end up with how's that
happy
so we have our vnav - now I'm ready to
actually launch into products rule
properly so it's going to be plus V U -
in this case is 1 + I've in community
ran out of space here plus u there it is
times V - well I just worked out what V
Dash was so let's just check the whole
thing in there
how we're doing so far I'll tidy that up
a teeny bit so we've got ten plus this
guy - this guy so far so good okay so we
have a derivative it's messy but I've
been told I have great confidence that
I'm differentiating the right thing and
I think you can go ahead you can check
my chain rule check my product rule I
think it looks all right now what are we
trying to do look back at the question
it says we are trying to maximize this
area so we're using the derivative of
area I'm going to find turning points
I'm hoping to find turning points when
now by the way I say May why do I say
may because I'm about to finish this
sentence with da on DX equals zero but
of course that's not a guarantee of a
turning point is it what would it be if
it wasn't a turning point it will be one
of these uh yeah one of these horizontal
points of inflection okay so that's why
I have to say they may exist so now I'm
going to try to solve this thing so I
get let's have a look at it
ten plus that minus that equals zero
okay now how many people at this point
thought oh what am I going to do here
right
it does look messy you it's not a
quadratic it's not a nice convenient
kind of thing that we've learned to deal
with so and it's entertainer test we're
going to say it's not I'm not used to
thinking polynomials in this case but
there is knowledge that you have that
can help us work with this can someone
give me a suggestion someone you got to
this point what could I do next that
might make this a bit easier any
thoughts
I could multiply through by the square
root of 100 minus x squared okay that
could work all right before I do that I
want to note then that also creates
problems it doesn't just solve problems
it creates problems it gets rid of this
square root down here that's good it
gets rid of this square root by making
it like a full whole thing with a power
of one but it adds it over here you get
the square root of 100 minus X but you
can't avoid it okay so do you think this
is still a good way to go still give it
a go because sometimes you have to be
patient with things right let's see what
happens I'm gonna get this
how's that that look okay did I have
multiplied through correctly it looks
good now this is still messy it's better
than this because at least it's got no
fractions in it but it still got this
square root and I really can't touch
that I have to resolve it in some way
okay so before I deal with that let me
just collect some like turns over there
plus 100 minus 2x squared does that look
right so what am I gonna do now what can
be done with this what's the normal way
you get rid of square roots you're
normally square hair right that should
give her a square root but you guys can
already tell me in its present form this
equation is not fit to be squared
because it's just gonna be like it's got
three terms in there two trinomial
you're going to end up with nine terms
at the end it's going to be an
unmitigated disaster so I need to do
that a tiny rearrangement here so that I
can square and it's not all four so what
rearrangement would you like me to do
/ - and then subtract the square roots
from both sides yeah let's watch what
happens if we take Eric's suggestion
I've got 50 minus x squared left on this
side on the right hand side I'm gonna
have you tell me minus 5 square root of
now just before we actually do some
squaring with this this is a situation
you've actually already met before just
not in the context of this kind of
question we met this before in lockers
do you remember that sometimes we would
say are the distance from like this
point to this point is always the same
for our variable point remember that
things like that okay and so what you're
saying was a distance distance formula
two points equals some other distance
right and we've seen this before you
square both sides until fine okay but
other kinds of LA Kiss's what I other
kinds of these things right they don't
ask it to you in this way they say maybe
the sum of this distance Plus this
distance is always equal to some fixed
number okay and when you square out like
this it's terrible it's awful
you have to rearrange things this is
what Eric's suggestion has done if I
Square now this thing will have no
square roots and this thing will have no
square roots so this is my best option
for getting rid of it so let's do it
I have space here left hand side what am
I gonna end up with 2500 takeaway 100 x
squared plus X to the 4 we'll come back
to that guy in a second right hand side
negative 5 times negative 5 25 all
multiplied by that thing is no longer a
square root because we squared it okay
now well let's just pause for a moment
and contemplate because at this moment
I'm sure a lot of you hit the panic
button because you're like that's
aquatic I'm not supposed to get cortex
in the tune of course okay
that's true kind of it's a quartic at
the moment but in a minute we're going
to turn into a problem that you can deal
with and you're very comfortable with to
get there let's just let's just simplify
this I can do a lot of simplifying here
right I've got some like terms to
collect so I'm gonna rearrange this to
know X to the 4 is at the front I've -
hundred x squared here how many X
Squared's are over here - 25 so I will
add 25 x squared to both sides which I
think leaves me with that number of X
Squared's yeah okay I have 2500 over
here yeah but I also have 2500 over here
don't I so in fact if I just subtract
from both sides then I just gets here
how's your brain doing so far can you
see yes it's a quartic but it's a core
trick that is very easy to tame cuz look
I can just pull out a common factor
right namely x squared that leaves me
with x squared takeaway 75 and this is
quite doable right um x squared what's
the solution that comes from this factor
x equals 0 but that's not what is this a
bond right X equal 0 it doesn't give you
a bond so you can disregard the solution
we're gonna get from here okay what
about here well if I factorize it might
be a bit clearer the difference of
squares again there's a solution here I
can disregard which one the this X +
return 5 gives me a solution a 0 of
negative roots 35 which is which is not
good right so I'm gonna say here x
equals all of these solutions but X is
ground zero reason it's always a reason
what's the reason length thank you very
much okay so from here I have my one
solution you can tie you that thing up
okay I think from there it's not too
dramatic to work out what your actual
area is it's just a substitution are
there any questions so I know a lot of
you is for the sake of time
yeah what that probably means is you
will need to have a look at earlier
questions if you ran out of time on this
question then this question was not the
problem it was the early ones that ended
up taking too long that's that's what
happens with last questions on exam okay
so maybe you want to find what's the
question which just took you forever or
you you didn't arrive at the solution
quickly and so that's sucked up your
time you didn't get there okay